you know what you know steve Schirripa
yeah so shrimp Oh Riviera yeah so he
calls me and goes hey Co cuz dice used
to call me Ching right so Steve stripper
used to call me King right as a king
that's what they used to say not racial
but I know it was racial through the a
Ching I go hey we're doing this midnight
dirty show I wanted a headline I'd never
had one before so Brian Etheridge and
Aron Kader were open Microsoft the time
the who will drive you I mean we don't
have to see that right so they drove me
out there so we're on Las Vegas
Boulevard these two sisters drive by
right and Brian as Moses driving and the
two sisters roll down the window maker
yes can not to Brian because he's the
Uglies like that I've ever seen or me if
they were saying it's a cater potatoes
are [ __ ] cute Kim look a good-looking
kid right cater runs out of the car
jumps in the [ __ ] truck they drive
out into the sunset right and me I'm
trying are [ __ ] mad all right so then
we get to the Riviera I go Brian equal
do own thing I have to concentrate right
off my set list or whatever so then
midnight I'm literally on stage and I
see Brian and Erin bringing these two
sisters or was like a 300-pound white
lit girl and the other one was 80 pounds
but they were sisters and they have
missing teeth but you know at the time
you know I need you know so anyway after
the show and cuz hey don't do us the
room to leave the room and so you know
you know condom either your main crowd I
know so we were doing it you know doing
it and doing it and then all of a sudden
like three hours later I'm with the stat
one and Erin's with this skinny one I
don't know Brian it I don't know where
Brian it so I look around the room I
don't know Brian is really in the bath
is not in the bathroom so I keep doing
up for doing but doggy style with this
that one and I feel something tickling
my butthole it was like a feather you
know I mean I turn around
it was like our normal you know me I
thought like a paranormal to go to sit
on your bum yeah yeah but then like I
keep going and I find ice I definitely
feel something you're like option like
something you know me and I look down
Brian had crawled underneath my
money and she was eating her [ __ ] all
I'm having sex with her now let me tell
you something something you have to
imagine what is on this face not at this
point yeah my little [ __ ] [ __ ] you've
got [ __ ] [ __ ] fat juice you know man
mix together you know I mean who knows
what kind of you know is I'm not just go
for the [ __ ] what do you I don't know
but he goes she likes it she likes it I
don't like it like his chin is rubbing
it my taint I don't like it it's weird
right I can't get hard so it gets worse
so I decide to powerbomb her right cycle
you know how you do it
taro I get a couple percent of our [ __ ]
nobody time you hear all right like that
you know me and you know I flipped out
right so I just kind of stick it back in
and put Brian had moved up right and a
rub against is on right so then we all
disband you know me because like I see
screen you know man like why we got a
fight why you down you know me you're
purposely purposely you know so then
afterwards we go to breakfast so I'm
taking these two girls out for
preference errands and we're talking
laughing I just can't wait to go to
sleep
and I look at Brian from across the
table his left eye completely closed
red yellow film a yellow film had closed
a shot like an adhesive right I could do
we gotta go to the hospital
there's no I'm good I go no you're not
good you can't [ __ ] see out of the
eye
it's like infested it's red it's like
pulsing you know which is his [ __ ]
fall right so then we go to the [ __ ]
arm hospital all right now we know sleep
you know man disaster right and which
I'm in there with them you know I mean
with them I like will be in the same
right because I'll just make something
up so the doctor goes what happened and
he goes he skull-fuck me he points at me
so I skull [ __ ] them
he kind of did now guys like that you
know
did you can check your dick because like
what was on your dick that made his
ankle is up dude it was not just my dick
the Jews at all kinds of stuff man
dude I can't believe my cloud I just I
went to the doctor two weeks ago and I
got all tested on my shits clean dog all
right
nothing I have no diseases you know me
no diabetes